[Musique]
en apparence c'est une famille heureuse
aliochine cannes et leur fils âgé de 5
mois pourtant 2020 moshin musulmans a
été accusé à tort d'avoir convertis de
force sa femme un doux à l'islam il a
passé un mois et demi en détention on
m'a accusé de mener un love jack
pourquoi crie-t-il all of jihad nous
sommes juste marier par amour nous
n'avons commis aucun crime ce n'était
pas un mariage forcé je ne lui mis
aucune pression et encore moins menacé
le loeuff jihad ou jihad de l'amour en
français une théorie conspirationniste
inventé par l'extrême droite indienne et
selon laquelle des hommes musulmans
épouserait des femmes dans le but de les
convertir à l'islam et de remplacer la
majorité hindoue du pays
cette thèse islamophobe fait pourtant
l'objet d'une loi en ou tard pradesh un
état du nord de l'inde où vivent machine
et alia son but criminaliser les
mariages interreligieux et les
conversions d'une peine pouvant aller
jusqu'à dix ans de prison
après l'arrestation de son mari alia dû
faire face à des pressions de jeunes
militants appartenant à un mouvement
extrémiste hindou l'ultra violent quatre
jeunes de ce groupe sont venus chez moi
ils m'ont posé énormément de questions
et à la fin ils m'ont poussé à accuser
mon mari
il était très menaçant il me disait
qu'il lui ferait du mal
et voire même qu'ils étaient capables de
le tuer
si elle avait cédé à leurs pressions
j'aurais passé des années en prison six
ou sept voire plus avec ce gouvernement
au pouvoir ils se sentent invincibles
ils font ce qu'ils veulent
rien qu'en 2021 près de 200 hommes ont
été arrêtés souvent après une
dénonciation calomnieuse à l'origine de
cette loi le bjp le parti nationaliste
du premier ministre marraine g audi en
quelques années à peine le bjp a fait de
loutard pradesh un état de 240 millions
d'habitants le laboratoire de son projet
politico religieux
son nom linde va l'idée selon laquelle
l'inde est une nation avant tout un doux
au détriment des autres religions
à la tête de cet état depuis cinq ans
cet homme un proche du premier ministre
lemoine fondamentalistes yogi a dit ian
hâte au nom de la défense des valeurs de
l'hindouisme il a multiplié les mesures
controversées
interdiction de vendre de la viande
autour des temples fermeture des
abattoirs des secteurs en majorité
tenues par la communauté musulmane dans
la ville de campo réputé pour son
industrie du cuir près de la moitié des
400 tannerie sont à l'arrêt aux deux
bêtes à ces machines sous scellés 2
millions de travailleurs dépendent de
cette artisane
beaucoup de personnes travaillaient ici
mais maintenant ça ressemble à un
cimetière
meyer jamal fabrique des ceintures pour
les policiers les militaires de tout le
pays les stocks sont abîmés sec pour cet
artisan la fermeture des tanneries est
un prétexte pour s'en prendre à la
minorité musulmane à la tête de la
filière bovine du pays
le plus triste dans cette histoire c'est
que nous avons le sentiment que les
autorités veulent détruire notre
industrie
simplement parce que c'est la communauté
musulmane qui la contrôle
al'inverse le gouvernement indien
multiplie les projets à destination de
la majorité hindoue du pays à 300 km à
l'est de caen pour bénarès considérée
comme la plus simple des villes
indiennes chaque jour des milliers de
pèlerins viennent méditer ou bien se
purifier dans le gange le fleuve sacrés
de l'hindouisme
et depuis quelques semaines à deux pas
des berges les dévots peuvent aussi
visiter cet ensemble monumental flambant
neuf qui relie la rive à des dizaines de
tombes le rénover comme celui-ci dédié
au dieu shiva
coût total 45 millions d'euros une
promesse de campagne du député local le
premier ministre navin g audi lui même
dont bénin c'est la circonscription de
quoi ravir ce prêtre qui gère le site
religieux
l'inauguration de ce lieu par notre
premier ministre l'honorable narendra
modi a été un événement fantastique pour
notre culture tout les hindous du pays
seront impressionnés par ces temples
quand ils viendront un pèlerinage
une inauguration en grande pompe
retransmise en direct par toutes les
chaînes de télévision indiennes
une cérémonie religieuse durant laquelle
le premier ministre a prié avant de
s'immerger dans le gange
dans son discours narendra modi convoque
l'histoire en s'attaquant à aurangzeb un
empereur musulmans du xviie siècle
coupable à ses yeux d'avoir voulu
détruire la civilisation indienne
les envahisseurs ont attaqué cette ville
et ont essayé de la détruire l'histoire
témoigne des atrocités de la terreur
exercée par aurangzeb un homme qui a
essayé de changer la civilisation par la
force de l'épée qui a essayé de piétiner
notre culture avec son fanatisme
redonner à l'inde sa grandeur passée un
message clairement adressé à son
électorat à la veille d'importantes
élections régionales
je voterai pour le bjp car ce sont les
seules à protéger notre culture indienne
et à donner de l'importance à
l'hindouisme
tout ce qu'il fait tout ce qu'il dit
valorisent les hindous il nous unit et
nous rend fiers de qui nous sommes
ces dernières années plusieurs rapports
des ong internationales ont dénoncé un
climat de haine grandissante dans le
pays et une explosion du nombre d'
attaques contre des minorités
religieuses